the gasa strip is a densely populated
area with more than 2 million residents
stretching for 25 miles between Israel
and Egypt but just underneath this
sprawling landscape another layer exists
a vast Labyrinth of tunnels the
underground maze was largely built by
Hamas the group designated by the us as
a terrorist organization controls the
Palestinian Enclave as Israel prepares
for a potential ground offensive in the
territory following a broad assault by
Hamas on October 7 the Subterranean
Network could play a key role so here's
why experts say these tunnels could make
Urban combats costly for both Israeli
soldiers and Palestinian
civilians the underground network has
existed for decades inside
Gaza previously it was largely used as a
rout to smuggle goods and weapons from
Egypt into the narrow strip of land
that's twice the size of Washington
DC but since then the tunnels have
evolved to become a key military asset
for Hamas I went in 2014 with the IDF
into a Hamas built tunnel uh during the
the conflict at that time it was a
pretty crazy experience in a sense these
were pretty sophisticated tunnels I'm
about 6ot and they were um you know I I
didn't have to bend down at all in them
they were very well reinforced with
concrete there was uh Communications
lines running down the side of them and
then they also had uh like almost like a
sort of little rails or like a sort of
Railway Line running along the length of
the tunnel during Israel's 7we war on
Gaza in 2014 the Israel Defense Forces
or IDF said it destroyed 32
tunnels they were used to hide weapons
equipment and troops
but also allowed Hamas militants to
launch surprise attacks using crossb
underground networks in the years since
then Hamas has continued to develop its
tunnel infrastructure and Israel has
continued to Target
it this map based on a graphic shared by
the IDF represents networks of tunnels
that Israel said it
damaged I think the the expectation is
that there is still a significant
Subterranean Network that um Israel is
going to encounter if and when it goes
in into Gaza this time former Israeli
security officials say Hamas has built
hundreds of miles of underground tunnels
in the last year or
more Israel is readying for a possible
ground invasion of Gaza by carrying out
air strikes targeting the Subterranean
Network I think that the the Israeli the
strategy will be to try to destroy as
much of the T Network as possible before
they launch a ground Invasion however
the operation to destroy them could be
challenging for Israeli forces one of
the biggest issues is locating them Gaza
is a dense Urban environment and being
able to discern precisely where a
continuous tunnel which may in fact be
deep underground is located as opposed
to possibly natural Rock ETS of uh
slightly differing geology or a host of
other aspects of the builtup environment
that's a really hard challenge even if a
tunnel is located additional factors
including its depth can mean Precision
bombs can struggle to destroy it it
depends not only on knowing precisely
where the tunnel is beneath the surface
but on having the explosive power to be
able to damage a tunnel Network that's
beneath perhaps layers of concrete
possibly layers of metal whatever the
builtup environment entails inherently
as well as whatever materials have gone
into construction of the tunnel itself
and the net result is that tunnels are
relatively invulnerable in many cases to
air attack and un let say any Israeli
operation to destroy the Gaza tunnel
system could Complicated by the presence
of
hostages hamas's armed Wing said in the
statements on telegram that some of them
were being held in the underground
tunnels if uh the aim is to rescue
hostages they can't be detonating
explosives within the tunnel complex
which I kill everyone inside it's going
to require Ground Forces uh and
specifically tunneling forces who know
how to operate in these tight spaces who
have trained extensively in how to
minimize the risk of ambushes and uh how
to avoid uh triggering various booby
traps one 85-year-old hostage who was
released by Hamas said she had been
inside there are a huge um huge um
network of tunnels underneath it looks
like a spider entrances to the
Subterranean passageways can also be
hidden within residential infrastructure
experts say as War continues any mission
to Target the tunnels also brings risks
to
civilians